on your back
newly released body camera video shows
the suspect spit at officers after
punching another officer attempting to
arrest him
come on man let's do it it happened on
September 20th just before one o'clock
in the afternoon dispatch in Birmingham
Alabama received a 9-1-1 call reporting
a disorderly person in a park the
suspect was later identified as 28 year
old Theodore Williams body camera video
shows officers speaking with a victim
who reported William spat on him
turn up this way saw me with
oh God turned and started walking this
way
you can call that number in the bottom
right hand side into the three business
days to make sure it's ready before you
go down there so well I mean what is
there anything that I mean I'm supposed
to do this guy's clearly off his
medication I mean he's had it I don't
know what this guy's doing so uh once
you get your report if you get your
report if you want to press charges you
can take that um report down to the
magistrate's office and uh you can press
charges on them uh the address for the
magistrates I believe it's 808 um it's
on the back of the car it's just a
magistrate and have the address on the
back
oh
yeah I understand
leaving this area
I don't mean he spat on me I mean he
blew a massive absolutely
the video then shows officers look
through a backpack left behind at the
park they determine it likely belongs to
Williams
so this is his backpack
[Music]
I was gonna go down and see about the
phone
we got some pills Theodore Williams at
same time two other officers find
Williams walking nearby
okay
you wanna get us out
foreign
before officers can detain Williams he
runs off after hitting one of the First
Responders
where you going
separate body camera video shows
officers again catch up with Williams
what's the deal bud huh
what's the deal
what's going on man
video captures Williams threatened to
hit an officer before taking a swing and
running off
come on man let's do it
after that other officers continue the
search for Williams
category
and he probably like going towards South
Town I'm gonna circle around officers
then approach Williams and attempt to
tase him but miss
when another officer rushes toward
Williams the suspect spits in his face
foreign
after that there was a struggle in the
officer's body camera is knocked off his
chest when it's put back Williams has
his hands behind his back
inside everything
okay thank you
[Applause]
up there
today
there you go
I don't know if it's broken
all right man we're gonna get you up
nice and easy okay
thank you
video shows these same moments from
another angle
[Applause]
okay 24 and 13 13.
two three
wow
there you go
I don't know if this is broken
[Music]
all right man we're gonna get you up
nice and easy okay
as the recording continues officers can
be heard discussing the spitting
incident
s
a little big right look at me it's
beautiful
Williams then mentions his backpack that
police had recovered earlier I found
that book bag it's mine who was the last
person to touch it me or you
meant you abandoned in that Park
what'd you do that for why would you
abandon your own products after that an
officer checks to see if they're spit
anywhere on his body
man
[Laughter]
[Applause]
with that Williams is put in the back of
a squad card
I gonna put them back down tomorrow
I'll say all right
we got disconnected
no it's gonna be feeling he landed I
don't know we'll figure it out
let's get up man
okay
I think he's been icing you so much
because I tried to fight him in the
street
oh you tried to swing on YouTube
Williams now faces multiple charges
including assault with bodily fluids
physical harassment resisting arrest and
disorderly conduct reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie